car alphabets in your book America
beyond capitalism you say that the u.s.
is the wealthiest nation in history in
the history of the world why is that
well it's an extraordinary history we've
had no wars on our land for many many
years a hundred years no World War one
know what World War two we've had
extraordinary continent vast resources
we've been a very favored nation so we
are very very wealthy but I think the
wealth is extremely disproportionately
distributed the top one percent in the
American United States this is an
extraordinary number has more financial
wealth than just about they've got just
about half of it which is an
extraordinary fact it's almost medieval
now and I think that's one of the
problems with uh with our democracy why
the the distribution the way it is well
there's been a buildup of concentrated
wealth over time wealth begets wealth
wealth begets wealth in general that
there are experts disagree about how
much is inherited and then reinvested
but it's a very large percentage and
then once one achieves great wealth the
concentrations build up we see some of
these salaries in the hundreds of
millions of dollars for executives and
building up investment options and so
forth this is scandalous in the in
recent months in the minority
communities there's an extraordinary
history particularly black community
where people were not allowed to have
homes that were not allowed to have
farms their children then didn't
accumulate the financial wealth of
blacks and Hispanics is down in the one
two to three percent range of the
average of whites it's an extraordinary
when you look at the averages overall so
the concentrations are very very extreme
another figure I ran into and doing this
research is that in most recent data the
top two-tenths of one percent way way at
the top made more money on the sale of
stocks and bonds then all other
taxpayers taken together in the most
recent data that's 1999 it's probably
about the same now when we get the new
data those numbers are the detrimental
to democracy they're detrimental to any
idea of equality and I think we're going
to have to deal with that as the in the
coming period if we want to have a
healthy society have you seen any growth
in the wealth in in the black and
Hispanic community say over the last ten
or fifteen years and
would you categorize that growth and
wealth as substantial no I there has
been amongst some parts of the community
that is there are some black and and
Hispanic millionaires but when you look
at the average person in fact during the
last three years during the Bush era
that's not entirely due to the bush
policies wealth amongst blacks and
Hispanics is going down 27% White's it's
gone up on average about 2% there's been
a drop not arise in in wealth and net
worth of blacks and Hispanics
extraordinary kind of phenomenon we're
really moving in the wrong direction
James Glassman from AEI wrote this in
this morning's Washington Times richer
than our children he writes there's
reason to worry that the glorious period
of wealth Americana could be coming to
an end quote we may be at a point rights
of perceptive and unbiased analysts I
admire Byron wine of Morgan Stanley
where the children born in the 21st
century will be the first generation of
Americans since the Pilgrims landed to
live less well than their parents he
goes on the real danger is not what you
read about in today's newspapers yes the
dollar is weak against the euro and our
trade deficit high but those problems
are cyclical and transitory the budget
deficit exceeded four billion four
hundred billion dollars last year but
our government's debt is still far from
excessive your response to that sir well
our government debt is extraordinary
both the trade debt and the deficit most
people understand this what we're doing
is cutting back on tuitions higher
education people are having to pay more
tuition for cutting back on health care
we're cutting back on various social
services at the local level at the local
state and local level people are feeling
the pain and the deficits are growing
and growing I disagree with that
entirely with our modern technologies
with proper economic management this is
this is the richest country in the
history of the world I think over this
coming century if we manage our affairs
properly we should see an increase in
wealth and income for everyone in the
society as we did in the 20th century
that's a matter of question of policy
and and politics driving policy
how can wealth be better distributed
well there are two ways to go at it the
one is the classical way which is
taxation this
which is taxation at the very top all
the Democratic candidates I noticed this
year asked for a repeal of the Bush tax
cuts for the top 2% in California this
year they passed a referendum
overwhelmingly the top millionaires were
taxed in order to provide money targeted
for mental health care in New Jersey the
last year that people over 500,000 we're
talking about very very tough groups
were taxed and the money was used to
offset regressive property taxes even
the virginia state of virginia's rather
conservative even the senate last year
passed legislation was which tax people
over 150,000 in the to deal with their
deficit so that was washed out when
there was a negotiation with the house
but i think there's a growing
understanding one part of this is
taxation the part i'm much more
interested in is building up different
ways that wealth can benefit communities
at large for instance over the last 30
years or so there have been a buildup of
worker owned companies where the wealth
is owned by the workers these are not
marginal anymore there are 11,000 of
these companies all over the country and
indeed more workers involved owning in
their own companies and participating
and having a stake in it more workers
involved now than there are members of
unions in the private sector so that's
the sort of thing I'm very interested in
and why I called the book of America
beyond capitalism because it's these new
forms of ownership in which in this case
workers own neighborhood groups there
are 4,000 neighborhood corporations in
which owning housing and land on behalf
of the neighborhood provides resources
for the neighborhood it's a different
way in which wealth it's a not
capitalist not socialist we don't know
what to call it but this has been
developing I think partly because of the
pain and difficulties at the local level
partly because of dislocation but
there's really quite an exciting a new
pattern just below the surface of what a
lot of the press has been watching on so
the positive changes in wealth ownership
are what interests me as much as
challenging some of these high
concentrations at the top and so we have
a better understanding can you tell us
what the average salary is of the
persons in that top 1% that you're
talking about well when you get to the
top in 1% it's in the the average is an
interesting number because it has the
very very very top and then it has
everybody else the average is about 1.3
to 4 million but when you go way up
you see this in the press every day I
think that you saw the Disney head I
think was seven hundred million dollars
eight hundred million dollars so there's
averages them tell you the whole story
they're very very concentrated at the
top like medieval kings and queens in
some sense but we just don't quite face
these facts we're talking with gar
alperovitz the author of America beyond
capitalism and the numbers are there on
the screen two oh two six two six a six
to eight rather zero two zero five if
you support the President to zero to
seven three seven triple zero two if you
support the Democrats and to zero two
six to eight zero one eight four if you
support all others our first call comes
from Asheville North Carolina good
morning good morning I would like to
know what your opinion is on the
taxation policies that Bush gave to the
wealthy and why you think that America
has voted him in tries and he in my
opinion totally ineligible to be
President and personally I think that he
they ran on God guns and gays and moral
issues that that really don't affect
most of our lives sir well on the tax
issues I I think the bush program has
been irresponsible first in giving away
so much of the nation's wealth to the
very very top groups and you know many
friends of mine were conservatives say
what what is going on with a so-called
conservative presidency that's creating
these massive massive deficits this is
not some fiscal policy as well as being
an equitable in my view so I disagree
and I think that we would need a strong
taxation policy to take us back why was
he elected some of us not sure he was
elected the first round in 2000 if the
Supreme Court had made the proper
decisions and now indeed in Ohio had
there been 60,000 votes going the other
way
would have had a different president so
I think a lot of it also had to do with
people not wanting to deal with the war
issue and challenging him sadly in life
in my view our next call comes from Key
Largo Florida a good morning yes you
said that the minorities both has gone
down 27 percent how does that match up
with the bush bush program that that
minorities are owning their own homes
and more numbers than ever and I think
it's more to like like Bill Cosby said
it's the priorities of what you do with
their money you know everybody has DVDs
and VCRs and TVs and everything else but
they seem not to be able to afford food
or insurance and stuff like that and I I
don't think capitalism is doing wrong if
you're gonna give a tax cut you should
give it to everybody because we are
equal we're equal as individuals you're
here you're you're Zdenek when we tax
people that make more money you're
making it like a bad thing to make more
money and I don't think that's good in
the capitalistic society well they're
lots of questions involved in in that
first the the facts are there's been
study by the Pew Research Center on this
the the wealth average wealth of
Hispanics and blacks went down 27
percent in the last three years secondly
as I mentioned earlier just take the
history of slavery and after slavery in
the South and many parts of the north
redlining
of African Americans could not buy
houses they could not get credit and if
your grandfather couldn't buy a house he
couldn't leave you credit and you
couldn't build up wealth over time and
this has been well studied that that's
one of the big big sources of the
disproportionate ownership of wealth and
that it's just discrimination
out-and-out so beyond that but also let
me give you an example in this tax
question it's just the opposite in many
cases that you suggest Social Security
taxes tax everybody the same until you
get to rich people and they cut off and
then after eighty eight thousand there's
no increased taxation if you make a
million or two million or three million
your attack
the same as someone making $20,000 so
there are places in the tax code that
are highly highly regressive not even
equal but saying that is you know for
many many years including even this
president this very conservative
president supports higher taxation on
the wealthy his taxes I would increase
them substantially I'd go back to the
Reagan era which were much higher or the
Eisenhower era which were much higher
and better economic performance
people forget that during the post-war
economic boom that's the best period
we've ever had an American economic
history incomes rising the top tax rate
was 91% so there is a way to manage
policy with significant taxes on the top
and have a healthy economy we know that
now Laurel New Jersey you're on with gar
alphabets yes good morning I had a
question I wanted to ask the gentlemen
it's a good topic you have on the day
because some of my friends we have
gotten together discuss issues such as
this relative disparities are could you
tell me what will be the feasibility of
having our special currency this for
example is called it blue money that
could be used circulated among a group
weird area the disparity or the reason
why is that it's because currency for
example minority areas only circulate I
believe two times and then it's gone for
good
what would be the practicality of the
Institute for example like blue money
that will be used among any group
regardless of race or that we use off
their disparities so that that money is
there will be circulated amongst those
people themselves and then that in
itself should offset this problem with
the disparity and I'll listen to your
response thank you well the it's very
interesting that there are in fact a lot
of experiments not with blue money but
there's something called time dollars
and and there are several places around
the country that exchange work for other
work for instance I will grandmother
will babysit and the plumber will help
her and but exchanging this is a common
buildup in many parts of the country so
that's worth worth looking at it's not
the central and
- what we're talking about but a point
you'd make is is related to this which
is buying local is also on the rise to
increase how much the money circulates
in given areas that is a possibility as
well and it's being encouraged by state
governments in some cities in North
Carolina there's one and an Oregon these
are important ways to rebuild the
community economic health which is
another part of this picture not just
individuals but the health of the local
community I take it up in the book as
well and trying to get at some of these
new experiments which are very
interesting was wealth distribution
adequately discussed during the most
recent presidential campaign know the
presidential campaign talked about
income distribution which is
extraordinary the you know the top one
percent is it another this is income
wealth is what you have income is what
you get each year the top 1% has more
income each year than the bottom hundred
million of Americans taken together
again it's very very extreme people did
talk about income and the Democratic
candidate was talking about some
increased taxation on income we haven't
yet got to the wealth issue but I think
the wealth issue just has to come
forward all the other European countries
tax wealth and these new experiments
where ownership of wealth can benefit
neighborhoods communities state
governments are doing investing half the
state governments now own some shares of
stock and companies cities are doing it
partly because the economic pain under
Republican and Democratic mayor's
there's a whole developmental process
underway very it's America beyond
capitalism as I say in the book Tampa
Florida good morning good morning to you
and appreciate this kind of stimulating
discourse on television at this hour I
would like to submit a perspective to
gar and then I would invite his response
as you sir continue to allude to the
European model where there is certainly
an underpinning of socialism and
historical legacy there if we were to
bring that over to the United States in
as much as we have a highly energized
capitalistic economic model I would
submit to you that through the
redistribution of wealth as you so
benignly referred to it what that means
is taking away from those who have
created wealth and perhaps that in of
itself
engenders a disincentive the creation of
wealth and the outcome possibly could be
what we're seeing in some of the
European nations with stagnant economies
because of so much social welfare the
removal of certain incentives for the
creation of wealth and the reliance on
the social welfare net in lieu of going
out and contributing in the classic
American capitalist model I invite your
response sir
well at first the only European model I
mentioned was the wealth tax that's the
only thing I've mentioned so far that I
think there's social democracy or
liberalism the welfare state strategies
of the 20th century are actually being
transcended all over the world but what
I'm interested in is particularly the
American down-home grassroots model
which is not that European model at all
that's these new institutions of worker
owned companies that are all over the
country good there's as I say there
eleven thousand of you probably got
several in your own area building up
wealth and it's a very decentralized
American Way neighborhood corporations
municipal governments doing all sorts of
things one very interesting one in
Michigan where they they trap this is
happening over the country as well but
Michigan in River View has they they tap
the gases coming off of the garbage and
that methane is kept away from the
atmosphere which has environmental
implications turned into electric energy
and also jobs and supplements taxes so
you the tax rate isn't as high cities
are getting very innovative partly
because of the pain and it's extremely a
very very American almost populist the
culture where people from the bottom up
are dealing with this in new ways and
very interesting ways just below the
surface how does our society go about
reclaiming reclaiming liberty and
democracy as you suggest in the book
well I don't think you can you know
people 35 years ago when asked in polls
do you believe the government does what
the people want and about four out of
five regularly 78 79 percent would say
yes the government basically does what
the people want something's happened now
thirty years later if you ask that
question it's just the reverse about one
in five say yes the government does what
the people want four out of five
basically say no it does what the rich
want it does
the corporation's want and does with a
special interests want basically there's
been some deepening awareness of just
what I'm talking about
but these concentrations of wealth
really drive elections they drive
lobbying in Washington if you've lived
in Washington as I do you just see it
all over the place that these
concentrations of wealth really begin to
distort our democracy so I don't think
you can really have a vibrant democracy
and I think the people know it that's
what the polls say when there is such
concentration so that's one piece of it
also I don't think you can preserve our
liberties unless we build a whole
Democratic culture in the new way we've
been incarcerated people again this is
we incarcerate more people seven times
as many as European countries per capita
and the minority communities are way way
off the charts
somehow over the last thirty years we've
been increasing since 1972 about six
hundred percent of increase of people
per capita going behind bars this is not
Liberty and that's before the Patriot
Act so there's something going on I
think many people understand the polls
show that we're gonna have to deal with
in a very very serious way over the
coming decade and start a much deeper
debate next up is York Pennsylvania go
ahead
hello thank you c-span good morning I'm
a college student
former undergrad and I currently cannot
find a job it's been a year over a year
I put out over 50 resumes and most of my
undergrad friends can't find a job as
well
since then I've decided to go back to
school for a master's degree
consequently I'm not I'm now being told
I'm not eligible for the same loans that
I receive just a year ago and my
question to your caller is is what is
your solution for this I mean I'm I'm
really having a tough time out in the
world in the workplace and I just I'm
looking for a viable solution well the
answer is just as I was one of the
causes the central causes have been a
cutback in government loan programs and
you're feeling it we feel it all over
the country that these very big
giveaways at the top and they have
they're responding to political power
that this is you know President Bush
said some thoughts about the tough
people the very very wealthy is the
haves and the have mores he said I
called them my political base those
cutbacks are real and they're hitting
and you're experiencing it I wish I had
an easy answer I think ultimately it's
going to take political activity and
changing these priorities back so that
we can begin to deal with the problem
you're talking about Fort Myers Beach
Florida you're on the Washington journal
morning the morning take my call all
right my question is primarily stems
from a historical point of view where
there's been more management on money by
government it seems that economies have
been more stifled rather than really
being improved and what I've noticed is
things like a Marshall Plan in Europe
after after World War Two and things
like that it's been praised in textbooks
as helping those economies get on their
feet
where I see however more government
involvement in the economy I see it
hurting things not actually improving
and I'd like to know why you think which
I'm sure you've studied economic
histories that you believe more
government involvement is what we need
well I've been talking about something
that is not your traditional government
involvement I've been talking about the
build-up of these new forms of ownership
a part of that does involve government
investment in a different way for
instance and again in the state of
California but many states big big
pension funds are used to invest not
only to make money but to keep jobs and
localities in the state and build up
jobs that's not just liberal California
the state of Alabama is a big very
conservative state is a leader in this
and they are using these resources
worker pension funds the workers been
paying for years both to provide
pensions and to get a better return than
some of the speculation in the stock
market over the last ten years and
secondly to invest in jobs even worker
owned companies a couple hundred in
Alabama this is public investment in the
right way but it's building up wealth
under these firms that are owned by
workers but also keep the jobs in the
local communities so in general I'm not
talking about the traditional strategies
but having said that look the Marshall
Plan was a government program you just
cited it as one of the main reasons
Europe got back on his feet and and the
government was deeply involved in the
best period of our economic history the
post-war economic boom so it's a
question of how we do these things not
not whether
George Bush has increased the size of
government relative to the economy not
decreased it and I think we're going
into difficult times with the big
deficits we're gonna Baron that the real
problems yet there's a bigger government
it's the wrong way to do it in my view
there's a story on the front page of
this morning's New York Times about
college students bearing more of the
cost of their education and smaller
sized Pell grants is this gonna have an
effect on the redistribution of wealth
in the next 5 10 15 20 years it's going
to have it's already beginning to have
an effect in two different ways one very
good students who are the people who
will make more money are being kept out
particularly minority students but
everywhere this is not just a minority
question they just can't get in it can't
afford it anymore so secondly we're
gonna lose their talents and that's what
the economy ultimately runs on and third
they're gonna have to pay back huge
loans if they do get in so that their
capacity to build up wealth is going to
be hid and all of this can be targeted
back to the priorities at the national
level in which in many ways reflect this
underlying power structure of high
concentrations of wealth and power
Honolulu Hawaii go ahead for c-span I'd
like to I'd like you to help me with my
dream my dream is that the white males
it gave us Ronald Reagan little Danny
Quayle George Bush jr. and those folks
I'm hoping that one day they'll realize
that they cut their own throat and since
since you talked about post-war that
means that you know the statistics
so before before Ronald Reagan no I'm
sorry I want to go back to Nixon before
Nixon when the when the dollar and gold
were tied at $35 an ounce
one person could raise a family a
blue-collar worker made enough so that
he could support his family sent on the
college and so on then Richard Nixon cut
the tie between gold and the dollar and
the price of gold went from $35 an ounce
to 600 which means that each one of
those little green pieces of paper was
worth less
that's when the that's when the little
woman had to go to work then Ronald
Reagan came along with what George Bush
Senior called voodoo economics
deregulated and if you're not if you're
old enough you remember when there used
to be savings and loans go ahead with
your question my question is is it as
obvious to you as it is to me that a
succession of Republican presidents has
cut the throat of working people and
brought us to the point that we're at
today well I think that's a little bit
oversimplified but I would put it this
way that economic polit this is again
our technologies have advanced that's
the basis of economic development that's
the basis of wealth and the basis of
income at the same time that
distribution of what's been produced and
it has been under Republican bail so
some Democrats has been moved way way
down in just the way that you say it you
know in 1948 the great American
economist Paul Samuelson in his textbook
said you know here's how trying to
characterize this he said if we took
kids building blocks and piled them up a
thousand dollars for each block most of
us would be less than the yard from the
floor the very wealthy would be at the
Eiffel Tower and he had to redo that in
the year 2000 we'd still most of us be
down here at about a thousand but most
but the top people would not be at the
Eiffel Tower anymore
maybe a Mount Everest so something's
going on we've allowed this to happen in
part because of politics and because of
the way in which money and power
actually move our politics in a way to
support what they want just as you say
it used to be possible to raise a family
one person working that's not possible
in the richest country in the history of
the world and and in my view that's a
shame and a tragedy that really has to
be a dealt with gar alphabets is a
professor of political economy at the
University of Maryland and serves as
president of the National Senator Center
for economic and security alternatives
he's all he also oversees the project on
general disarmament and is one of the
founders of the committee for the
political economy of the good of Sakana
me of the good society our next call
comes from Greenwood South Carolina good
morning good morning go ahead a couple
of questions
you think your solution seems to be just
tax the rich more sir couple of
questions you have a Democratic governor
in New Mexico I believe bill Richardson
who has cut the taxes in that state I
think about 50% - in this industry to
come in there one other thing here a
couple of other things the reason people
are paying incarcerated are in jail of
the culture committing crimes I want us
to go the socialist way of Europe
service this is not the way to go thank
you
well let me just address this if you
look at that this crime question what
you call a crime and whether or not it's
a crime or whether or not you treat drug
ailments and so forth is a very real
question that where the line is drawn
most European countries on this issue
and indeed a very conservative judge
Judge Richard Posner they said look this
country is going we now put more people
in jail than virtually any other per
capita than any other country except the
Muslim Islam countries this is off the
charts now if you look at the statistics
something odd is going on and what we
define is a crime what we don't define
as a crime so that's part of it
but one of the things that's happening I
think as I said earlier is that the very
very wealthy I'm not talking about the
suburbs the subject suburbs and the
middle class have been taxed themselves
because we've not been taxing these top
groups properly and as I said earlier
that we know from our own history this
is not European history this is American
history in the post-war economic boom
top tax rates and even under Eisenhower
we're in the 90% range not down in the
30% range it's gone way down at the same
time the difficulties in the country as
you have as you've discussed earlier you
can't raise a family unless two people
go to work something very odd is going
on here this is not European stuff let's
talk about America and our own history
in the book you just you recommend a
shorter workweek explain why well over
time the American workweek has gone from
80 hours at the beginning of the century
last century and is down to a little
over 40 hours why is that that's because
technologies become more and more
productive and we should be using our
time for education for the Arts
for getting involved in the community
but it stopped stopped about mid-century
a very very wealthy country over the
next century in theory and indeed in
practice were almost certain to do as
well in the next century probably better
we're going to be wealthier and
wealthier in terms of our capacities
probably seven times as wealthy if we
produce the same thing as the 20th
century now we can turn that into a
million dollars for every family on
average or we can cut the work week from
40 hours to 35 or 30 hours and people
gonna have more time we're gonna have a
choice about what to use our wealth for
again if we can manage the economics of
it and the politics of it correctly that
takes a political will and people waking
up to what's going on the last call for
this segment comes from Hamden
Connecticut good morning good morning
how are you both fine go ahead okay I I
just like to say I am constantly amazed
this is the most baffling problem that
that I can think of is how the
Republicans and the people with a lot of
material and finances can manage to
sucker in a majority at an election year
after year when they're shown to live in
we also I built how Bill Clinton lived
he wasn't a millionaire or anything like
that but look these people have ranches
and they go first class
anyway I'm always amazed to see that I
just wanted to say one more thing and
then I have a question for you sir if
you think about it I have an income of
about fifty thousand a year right from
that point of view I'm at a disadvantage
a total disadvantage
I'm totally unequal to say Ross Perot
because if I want to run for president
there's no way I can he can set up a
whole party just to foster himself to do
it
but sir I wanted to say that I think
everything you said is very interesting
and I wonder how you see
the attempt to change over the social
security to the stock market Thanks
well on the last question I think the
president's proposals when they are
defined are going to be rejected by the
large best vast majority because it's
going to put people at real risk if he
doesn't and the risk that the stock
market will go down with just when you
need it
either that or very very large deficits
are going to increase I do want to say
one thing I'm from Wisconsin originally
and I was brought up in the McCarthy era
there were difficult times people
thought nothing would ever change but
actually after that there was a major
Progressive Era the civil rights
movement came out of a very dark period
so did the environmental and so did the
conservative movement once a minority
movement built up over time so in
general these things can change if
people get serious even when there are
difficulties at the national level
building up from the bottom is a
historically very well understood
process we can challenge these things in
the long view in my in my opinion so but
it takes people saying it's time to
change things and time enough is enough
gar alperovitz is the author of America
beyond capitalism thank you very much
for being on the program